and when have Steve invited me to talk
here I gave us I research your brother
in the state and said you know what I
what's going on here sort of big picture
okay
that's whatever it's my clan so I'll
talk about several topics that are close
to my heart
deliberately I decided not to use slides
actually have slides in front of me
results should I show those slides and
then I realize that now slides are evil
they make people concentrate on this
slides and not on the talk so there will
be no slides but I will reveal the title
some observations on platforms frictions
and classical economics
so let me start the obvious question
where what do those three platforms have
in common right share platforms public
clouds and mechanical truck well they
have a lot of things in common of course
but there are a couple of things that I
can want to point out that I think I
interesting so first of all all three of
them reduce frictions and they enable
higher utilization of resources that's
what they do
and all three create homogeneous goods
at the place where previously those
goods were not quite as homogeneous so
let me explain what I mean so let me
start with public cloud so as a first
order approximation and as I will later
tell you that approximation is not such
a great approximation that's not a
terrible one public cloud turns compute
in the commodity so cuz CPU cores where
a commodity more or less for a long time
but there's a difference CPU is a stock
you buy CPU you put it on the desk and
that's a stock and that stock is very
much illiquid it's very very rare for me
to knock at your door or your proverbial
door and say hey it looks like your
company has this you know 200 CPUs
sitting under your desks not being used
that much why won't I take those for a
week or so or for an hour or so so
that's that's not a conversation we can
have CPU is not liquid the flow is not
liquid and of course public cloud makes
it liquid CPU provides a stream of
services that could be easily shifted
around so that flow becomes commoditized
when it wasn't before so of course that
movement from full from a stock being
as a commodity to flow that the stove
generates becoming a commodity it's
pretty common so look at rework that's
kind of what they do too right
but with real estate look at modern
rental markets that evolved while you
know the rental market today is is a
relatively well-functioning market we
have standard agreements we have like
relatively low transaction costs so you
know renting an apartment 200 years ago
was probably more difficult ordeal and
so so it's just general part of
development of financial systems of
course so now let's look at rideshare so
what is it
that right share turns into a commodity
and that by the way is not a rhetorical
questions actually non obvious question
does it turn anything in the commodity
that wasn't a commodity what does it
turn into a commodity any suggestions
that's right share turn and anything in
the commodity lets lets us do Shore show
of hands who think that it really
doesn't relative to you know whatever
taxi and limo industry that existed
before so who think that it does so what
does it turn into a commodity what is it
that became a commodity that didn't that
wasn't a commodity before okay but the
cars were commodity I mean I can buy a
car and rides we're in some sense the
same kind of commodity I can call up
before uber I can call up a limo company
and I could say I would like a ride from
A to B at this hour and they would say
yes sir and they would send a black car
for me which was very very popular in
New York starting from like nineteen
eighties way before
uber so that it's not entirely obvious
how it got commoditized so what else is
being commoditized here huh your free
time is commoditized and who are you a
researcher or
yes exactly so I what what is really
being commoditized here is drivers time
and drivers time is kind of not driver
as a stock right so we all of us have
jobs and there's a relatively fluid
labor market right you apply for a job
you kind of know what kind of job you
can get you get more or less what you
think you deserve if your expectations
are realistic so we have a relatively
fluid market for labor so just like we
have a always kind of relatively fluid
market four cores four CPUs
but here the story becomes a little bit
different so when when you get a job a
risky sell your labor but now that flow
that your labor generates is no longer a
commodity you are not unless you work
for a temp agency or something you are
really not up for rent you know you work
somewhere it's a relatively sticky
relationship your wage is not
renegotiated every week right so so
that's what changes with right share you
turn labor into flow in the same way in
which public cloud turns our cores in
the flow that could be have seamlessly
traded and you as a worker you can start
working anytime and you just keep
selling that flow of your labor services
Sanchez something that we may that looks
like a spot market right you you're
working at a day when demand is
unusually high the price is surging you
make double the money like you know last
time there was a snowstorm and in
Seattle I the the uber price was surging
something like over 2x and I asked an
uber driver how are you doing and he
said well you know my triple the money
relative to usual
few drivers on the road double the
prices also demand for passengers it's a
good day when there's a snowstorm at
least sometimes right so so that's
that's a different story you have
basically a spot market for labor so by
the way I think that's something that
makes rideshare quite interesting and
unusual because that kind of spot market
for you know turning capital goods in
the flow when you rent them has a long
history right real estate you know most
businesses that operated 150 years ago
almost all of them owned the premises
they own the real estate they used today
Telegraph I when you go to university
when you ask those businesses do you own
the the real estate that you're using to
grow the business usually the answer
would be no in fact it's basically the
same family who owns most of the real
commercial real estate on sulwon Avenue
which is one of the busiest business
streets in Berkeley right so that's
that's a different model so so it's
common to turn those capital goods in
the flow or it is not uncommon but
turning labor into the kind of flow is
actually quite unusual
most people have jobs the jobs have a
certain wage and that wage doesn't
doesn't look to it from day to day from
year to year wage is kind of uh it's
actually almost impossible to lower the
wage is very very rare to lower the way
you can lower other parts of
compensation like bonuses but there's
some lower bound that's relatively high
so that's what really makes right sure
quite quite different and quite
interesting you have this almost a dream
of a classical economist this kind of
general equilibrium where labor becomes
more of a true commodity for better and
for worse and of course it's on all of
our minds because of recent
legislation in California that basically
makes it harder for ride-sharing
companies to classify drivers as
contractors so okay so mmm so definitely
in some sense those platforms built
cloud with Mechanical Turk will be built
right share they brings us they they
bring us a step closer to something that
resembles a general equilibrium economy
where you can have seamlessly reallocate
resources which could be a good thing
but it's also not without serious
drawbacks
but before we talk about kind of the
good and the bad things about community
commodification let's kind of go down a
little bit down the memory lane down the
let's look at economic history a little
bit so first of all there is nothing new
about creating commodities in fact the
entire history of modern economics of
modern economy not modern economics is a
history of communication so many things
that today we think of as commodities
pork belly grain oil barrels apples
whatnot those are things that today are
very much commodities your table was the
journal you see the price for those
commodities they're liquid commodities
and yet s and I don't know how many
people here are kind of students of
market design and how many people are
coming from different disciplines and
areas but if you are a student of market
design you are almost certainly or
probably know that those things weren't
always commodities they very much
weren't because not all barrels of oil
are created equal not all apples are
created equal and people knew it very
very well 200 years ago when you wanted
to buy apples gee well apples were
different
well apple trees were different someone
really sour someone sweet they were all
different and different sizes different
everything different number of warms in
them so so you know you look at the
apples you see what you get you you
haggle for the right price given the
quality so how could you talk about
apples being a commodity when so
different in quality so similarly with
gray
different grains have different dances
it's the same same plant but depending
on the soil depending on many factors on
the water availability it would have
different density different size
different many things different
percentage of who different humidity and
so on and so forth right so again that
matters that influences the price and of
course with oil well it's very much not
a commodity because if you look at the
Saudi oil versus far eastern oil a
really different very very different
oils they actually have very different
chemical compositions and that really
influences kind of the process of
refining that oil into something else
but people said look let's figure out
some kind of standard where we'll have a
canonical commodity here's a standard
apple here's a standard barrel of oil
and then whenever something is slightly
non-standard do you have a complex table
for adjustments so this oil is different
from canonical by this match we know
that it's 12% less valuable because of
this and this so you create a certain
system of standardization and adjustment
so the reason that all those things are
the commodities today is because of
because humans made them so because we
created a fictional unit of standard oil
no pun intended and and then we kind of
learn to convert actual oil into the
standard unions and by the way for
example one of the things that makes a
big difference for oil is where it is
because transportation is expensive so
standard unit of oil is I believe in
this particular point where standard
unit of oil is located which I think in
Louisiana but I'm not sure right so so
it's a process
so what did what happened when we have
this communitisation of things we know
that the prices of commodities are
notoriously volatile in fact for example
if you look at coffee prices like crazy
they could change several times
depending on the harvest as they should
right because you have relatively
inelastic demand so you have an enormous
volatility
it's common for commodities to be very
volatile for kind of fairly obvious
intuitive reasons so the first question
is okay so commodities a notoriously
volatile but is it something intrinsic
about those goods or are things becoming
more volatile because they become
commodities and you can pay easily right
a theoretical model that would imply
that when you turn something in the
commodity right so that has to become
more volatile so you can also write the
theoretical model where it doesn't
happen but it would be a little harder
so the intuition is very simple why
would things become more volatile when
they're commodity when they become
commodities let's say apples are not a
commodity you know a couple of farmers
you think this guy's good this guy is
really good this guy's okay you have a
pre-existing relationship with them you
know what their apples are you come you
you haggle you negotiate the price and
you know the guy with those expensive
apples you can tell him hey you know why
won't you sell me apples cheaper this
year and say well why you know why
should I sell you cheaper this year are
plenty of apples this year oh you tell
me every year that there are plenty of
apples this year that's what you always
tell me always try to get lower price
from me but look my apples are good sure
there may be some other bad apples that
are not very good but good luck finding
the same quality plus mine well you know
that's that's complicated actually the
search cost here is really high it's
it's complicated and again we write that
count contract not at the time when I
could examine your apples right so
someone else could promise me excellent
apples
but who knows what they will deliver
right how we're even going to write that
contract so there's not that much kind
of there's a very high search cost and
that would probably create huge
anchoring from previous previous year
prices so on the other hand once
commodity becomes extremely clear your
apples are a percent more valuable than
canonical apples we have this totally
fluid market canonical apples this year
there's just so many of them people
couldn't eat that much canonical apples
is here are five times cheaper than last
year so what are you going to get for
your apples well not much right so
creole or vice versa right this shortage
of apples the price of canonical Apple
is super high my Apple is almost as good
as canonical Apple it's also should be
super high so so theoretically you
should expect higher volatility so first
I think that it would be wonderful if
there were an economic historian so I'm
not aware of any papers that actually
compare volatility of goods before and
after communication so I have a
conjecture that it should think that it
has to increase
I know communities are very volatile but
I don't know of any papers that actually
document it empirically it will be very
interesting if someone were to look at
commodification and see if it actually
web two significant increase in price
volatility and if it did that tells you
something about what to expect in other
markets where we create communication
and one of them that seems most
interesting from this point of view
would be right share and the reason I
think right share would be quite
interesting from this point of view is
that here was being commodified is human
labor and that of course unskilled human
labor and a relatively unskilled and
that of course has huge ramifications
for well for people who work those jobs
and also for the society because you
know to some extent uber and lyft are
serving as
among other things nation's employer of
last resort they hire the nation's
unemployment insurance in some sense and
I think they're quite useful for
absorbing EDA syncretic shocks in the
labor market right so that if this a
person who just randomly lost his job
every year randomly exactly hundred
people lose the job they search for jobs
they need a job kind of in the meantime
you know right share comes to the rescue
in some sense and that's great that
really helps to absorb idiosyncratic
shocks and in some sense it's a huge
efficiency gain there but there is
something else going on there are also
as we know very well the systemic shocks
in the labor market
there are recessions when you have
significant unemployment so there when
there's a systemic shock would we
experience something similar in terms of
the price of labor as we experience an
other commodity markets wild wild swings
and if you do experience that first of
all the current oberon live drivers who
do it full-time
are they anticipating that hey come
recession the market equilibrium price
of whatever they would be earning could
drop dramatically in fact the market
equilibrium that's currently way above
minimum wage for most areas make me go
way below minimum wage what would happen
them so that that's certainly something
that I think is concerning and in fact
if you look at commodity markets there
are some commodity markets but because
of that volatility you know we simply
have you know large players writing
essentially insurance contracts right or
white players just swallowing the risk
right if you're Starbucks you can do a
lot of things to risk manage
and they're pretty well positioned to
swallow that risk you also see other
markets like us farmers where they
exposed to this enormous risk in
commodity prices and there you have
really government regulation system with
the USDA doing a lot to soften those
blows and I realize now I'm starting to
sound like a macro economist which I'm
not but that's what being a chief
economist makes me write like most of
the time I deal with micro issues but
sometimes like those macro issues come
my way and I find them interesting and
important so so that makes me think that
we really need to as a professional
economists as market designers we really
need to think more carefully about the
public policy problem around kind of how
we as a society could intelligently and
efficiently deal with this issue of
possible great volatility of ride
sharing drivers in time of recessions
where you can easily imagine demand for
a chair going down a bit because of
recession but then the supply of drivers
going way up because there are people
who couldn't make car payment they
desperate they want to drive but but
what does it do to the price it just
hits the bottom so well you can say well
it's okay it's a market market
equilibrium price but at the same time
hey commodification brings us closer to
geneva liberal vs economists we love
general equilibrium because it gets a
sufficient outcome but guess what in
general equilibrium there arrow-debreu
securities meaning that there's a
perfect insurance market implied in
general equilibrium but there is no
perfect insurance market for
ride-sharing drivers well maybe we need
to create one but you know are the laws
that are currently being passed that
reclassified drivers demand that require
us to find drivers as employees is that
kind of great solution well I can
certainly see why people may like that
solution I could also see why people may
do
like that solution because first of all
it's takes away that potential benefit
of basically have uber being the
employer of last resort where in the
absence of macroeconomic shocks it
really provides people valuable
insurance against idiosyncratic shocks
that they're experiencing so that that
could be a problem it could just in
general make things more cumbersome and
less dynamic also it's not clear that it
would help with it would exactly how it
would solve the problem or form kind of
declining of equilibrium wage during
recession right so it wouldn't be a good
thing if you have a red sharing company
during the recession where market
equilibrium price becoming much lower
just firing all the workers and hiring
new ones at much lower price it's not
clear that those laws would actually
solve this problem of price volatility
but certainly I expect that some
institution governmental or private
would emerge to somehow solve this
problem so of course you have somewhat
of similar problems with public cloud
but I will talk but of course it's much
less severe because with public cloud
you're not dealing with kind of
low-skilled poor people who could pool
absorb shocks right so public cloud that
part is not much of a concern because
the companies that provide the service
are very some of the largest companies
writers you know Amazon it's Microsoft
it's Google so those are the companies
that know how to think about risk that
know how to insure themselves and so on
and so forth that was a much less
subject to those price fluctuations
simply because cloud is actually not the
commodity the switching cost between
clouds is quite high at least at this
time there are some tools that kind of
try to make it easier for consumers to
switch the bow something is yet so but
let me talk a little bit about kind of
the cloud and draw a little bit of a
parallel parallel there with the
ride-sharing
so mmm it's a really cloud you can think
of cloud as one big sausage of you need
this much here's your piece you need
this much here's your piece you just
deal with it like any other commodity so
it's a really helpful model and I'm
going to indulge myself and you into
thinking about cloud in this way this
model is actually quite deeply flawed I
before I joined Microsoft I was chief
economist for Google cloud so once you
kind of look at the sausage from inside
of the sausage she realized they in the
sausage so I will talk about why it
ain't a sausage in like five minutes
but finale's pretended this associations
a really useful analogy just like confer
round course so so let's imagine that
cloud is simply compute resource and
completely homogeneous and everybody
needs certain amount and everybody has
fluctuating demands so then if you take
that view of the cloud then of course
it's dramatic efficiency improvement for
very obvious reason right if you
couldn't use public cloud you would have
to have your own stock of that resource
but since your demand that you
fluctuates you will have to basically
have quite a bit of that and you'd also
have have to keep it kind of on your
premises which would be more expensive
because your premises weren't
specifically built to be super efficient
for hosting those core other CPU
resources so this can have a clear
efficiency benefit from public cloud
and if you when you talk to businesses
about why they want to use public cloud
they say what agility matters for us
what really matters for us if there is
kind of a burst if we need a lot more
compute resources you know in two weeks
just being able to basically do nothing
and have more of those resources that's
that's super valuable
so this agility it's like the word
agility is very popular among cloud
buyers and that is why it's very popular
among cloud sellers because that's what
cloud buyers want so that that makes
sense that's where value comes from but
then there is a question okay so what's
the right way of selling that resource
and you know I'm basically a market
designer and an auction theorist so my
first instinct is to think about the
world as an auction even when it's not
even if you are talking about right
share driver for whom there is no
auction it's very useful to think about
it as an auction so let's think a little
bit about auction equilibrium price for
cloud well you would have let's say you
have a certain amount of CPU sausage but
it's not infinite that's the one you
have so then you have certain demand at
any point in time so the efficient thing
to do to simply allocate everything you
have to so the efficient thing is
allocate everything you have to the
highest value buyers and set reserve
price efficient reserve price would be
equal to a marginal cost by the way if
you're an economist you first guesses
that marginal cost of cloud is actually
zero because you already bought CPUs so
might as well use them that is action
not quite correct marginal cost is
actually not zero it's not zero because
cloud takes electricity so if I switched
off the CPU I save some money the
savings are actually not negligible
it's somewhere comparable to like 10% of
the cost of computers electricity it's
rough ballpark it could be more it could
be less whether that's like a rough
ballpark so it's not negligible but it's
quite low right so well would it be a
reasonable thing to do to basically run
an auction with the reserve price and
everybody who bids high enough gets the
resource and everybody who doesn't
doesn't get the resource seems perfectly
sensible right except that nobody does
it
that's not how Google sells cloud that's
not how AWS source code and that's not
how Asher sells cloud and those are kind
of the three major cloud providers you
know AWS has the biggest market share
and the azure is the second and the
second player in the space no none of us
do that there's some small part of
inventory that is sold using something
resembling an auction to some extent but
the bulk of what's being sold is not
being sold where an auction and if you
think about that the reason is pretty
obvious you have couldn't really saw it
as an auction and here's why remember
there are big switching costs between
clouds so when you come to Asher or when
you come to AWS when you come to Google
you pretty much commit to using that
cloud
you couldn't just flip a switch and five
minutes later go to another cloud in
fact it would be quite a significant
investment to move there's some
exceptions so and you certainly couldn't
move on one hour now geez so now let's
imagine that it was all sold where an
auction could you see what could go
wrong well demand for cloud is pretty
inelastic people who buy compute
typically our large businesses for whom
the cost of compute in most cases is a
small part of the cost right you know
when you're Ford Motor Company you're a
huge consumer of cloud when you're a
Walmart you made a huge consumer of
cloud but that's still very small part
of your overall revenue and and of
course it's a critical one so no matter
what it costs you're not going to just
walk away and say hey I'm going to use
less cloud so your demands on the demand
side is very little elasticity there's
some on the margin but not much so that
means that if you were to simply rely on
an auction if there's sufficient
capacity then the price would always be
pretty much price of electricity the
reserve price and then of course the
cloud provider would never be able to
recover its fixed costs so that's ain't
going to work nobody would want to be in
this business as a cloud provider right
so you don't want to run an auction with
have ample capacity the deficient level
of capacity and when you buy is it this
way
so in order to make money you would in
order to just recover your cost not even
make a profit just recover your cost you
would have to have some instances if you
are writing an auction you'll have to
have some instances where there is a
shortage of cloud capacity and that's
the times the spikes does you know once
a year once a month events where demand
is unusually high that's where you would
be making all your money but that of
course would create terrible incentives
for a cloud provider we all say oh just
have less capacity and we'll make more
money
that's brilliant well as a customer
would you like to buy a service like
that no it seems like a terrible idea
the customers say well wait a second so
I will be paying like basically almost
zero all the time and then I would be
paying through the nose maybe you know
hundred times a thousand
times the average cost because that
would be only during the time of the
shortage so that would not be a healthy
market that would not a good market by
the way think about the electricity
market that has a lot of commonalities
with this right there are some similar
problems but there are also some some
big differences particularly with the
electricity kind of bulk of electricity
is consumed by consumers like people
like you and me who don't think much
about it and who call consumers and of
course cloud is mostly consumed by
businesses and enterprises so it's
different quite significantly so so
basically to make a long story short I
hope I convinced convinced you or at
least explain to you why we just don't
see an option for cloud capacity as a
dominant model it would create enormous
risk for consumers the consumers are
here enterprises who would simply say we
we don't want that we would rather just
be safe and have our private data center
where things are totally predictable we
bought the course and they're good there
is no price fluctuation and it also
doesn't create you know you don't want
to create terrible incentives for cloud
providers you can make lots of money by
basically holding up your customers so
as a result what's majority of cloud
consumers basically buy cloud services
at pre negotiated prices
let us table basically fix them flat and
don't change much and basically that
there's an understanding that they
basically never go up right so in theory
they could of course might happen if it
is like some big shortage you know
there's some geopolitical event that
creates huge shortage for RAM of course
there was a shortage of RAM in the past
but the list price of RAM was not raised
maybe discount
that given given out during that time
we're a little lower than usual all the
old customers kept the same price they
were getting before maybe new customers
were getting a little bit less of a
discount but that's kind of that's how
the bulk of crowd is being sold and then
of course there's a very interesting
question of how do you sell the leftover
the unused inventory without
cannibalizing the rest of the market and
that's a really interesting question
that's one of the questions that my team
works on and so now that I kind of gave
you a big picture kind of general
equilibrium economics super simplified
story now let me add a little bit of
color of what the cloud market really is
and whatever kind of first order and and
second other things that we wrestled
with day in and day out so some of the
things that economists do for cloud and
my team spends like probably like at
least a third of our cycles is devoted
to working with Azure because it's such
a complex and interesting and important
market for us so one of the things is
like capacity planning and there are
really interesting capacity planning
issues there so for example you can you
to do it right you have to think in
terms of real options you have to think
okay we have we need to make sure that
there is enough capacity for all our
customers so you have a certain demand
forecast and as I I'll wait a second but
what's the time horizon what does it
mean to have enough capacity because if
I can predict today that there would be
a spike in a month well if I can
increase the capacity in the months so
that I can meet it in months later then
it's fine right but then you say oh but
there are different types of investments
here so for example just buying cores
may take relatively little time you know
you may be able to get the cores from
the manufacturer in you know it's a
consumer you can go to Best Buy Buy
cpu's as an enterprise you actually
couldn't do it because you know your
others are too big so the manufacture
may not have enough in stock but you
know there's a relatively short lag time
right if you have seen 90 days you can
be pretty confident that you can buy
enough course you have 90 days you can
be pretty confident you can buy enough
Ram much less time maybe sufficient
right 30 days may be enough most of the
time on the other hand you need to put
those course somewhere and you need
electricity to power them so it turns
out that data centers consume so much
power that you couldn't just plug it in
into an electrical outlet you don't plug
in a data center in an electrical outlet
a major data center is the thing the
size of a football field that consumes
more electricity than the entire city of
Berkeley so so you couldn't just plug it
into an electrical outlet and get enough
electricity to power it so building a
new data center one of the kind of
bottleneck that that could take like a
year or more is making sure that there
is enough electricity there you may have
to build a power plant right there so so
this electricity provisioning has a very
very long cycle right and so on and so
forth so you have different type of
things you need to buy in order to
provide cloud all of them have different
time window and of course you have to
have an intelligent forecast and so on
and so forth so now let's go back to the
sausage model is cloud real a sausage
well it actually isn't at all the number
of so the number of products that cloud
providers offer is not just in tens of
thousands I think it's more like closer
to hundred thousand so lots and lots of
different products and that's because
they're different types of VMs there's
different hardware the different Ram
different network different like network
configuration
and so on and so forth is a lot to a lot
of degrees of freedom there and on top
of that there are lots of different
locations and they matter too and for
some customers they don't matter for
example if I am doing scientific compute
I can run it in Japan I can run it in
California it doesn't matter because the
delay from running it in Japan would be
you know significantly less than a
second so no big deal on the other hand
if I'm running a real time gaming
service that delay really matters and
you really want to have that data center
that's nearby so that's again another
level of complexity and have these this
customers are not homogeneous for some
certain aspects matters for some they
don't and that's why we Microsoft has
lots of small data centers as you
imagine law of large numbers doesn't
work there as well so the higher cost
factor but it could be valuable for
customers who need low latency and so on
and so forth so I have three minutes
left I think there are two questions so
let me try to take those questions but
before that I would like to conclude and
the conclusion is very even interesting
times and there a lot of interesting
things to think about boss in theory and
in practice and I can try to give you
the taste
thank you and I'm not sure I understand
the question because like to some extent
spot market is more or less by
definition kind of an auction and people
that are competing for the CPU over the
spot instances or each person if I just
retail price that should be about that I
think like if I go to this that's right
that's right so so I think so I think
what you're asking a UI so let me let me
make sure in the study of a question so
I think you're saying look so it's some
unsold inventory that somehow being
utilized google has preempted
preemptable instances Amazon used to
have sport I think now they call it
something else and it's less of an
explicit auction so a questions like how
far those things from being a real
auction is that yeah so I think that so
in the case of Google at least last time
I checked it wasn't at all an auction
let's just say hey here's a flat price
but we could preempt you if there is not
kind of if you don't have enough
capacity and they also kind of I think
pre-amp preempted people
prophylactically just to make sure that
demand is not being cannibalized so AWS
used to have kind of more of an explicit
auction now it's much less much more
implicit where you say hey here's the
maximum I'm willing to pay they reserved
the price at the right to preempt you
they may or may not Priam the guy with
the highest price and so on super so
it's that's a little complicated
complicated so it smells a little bit
like an auction it's not exactly an
auction so was another question
excellent and you were wrong I have zero
minutes left but oh there's one more
question yes the worst thing you
you said the last few things your
description of the cloud computing it
suggests that it's actually not really
commodities this is too much
individuation going on and with that
explain so so I think it's a it's kind
of a longer question let's talk over
coffee but generally I think it's a lot
more of a commodity than the desktop
under your desk or that a private data
center and your data closet it is not a
commodity or not a perfect commodity in
a sense that different public clouds are
not perfect substitutes but within a
cloud certain if you take a fixed fixed
VM type within that cloud that fixed VM
type is in very significant way a
commodity so I do that and thank you
[Applause]